O ne o
[Müzik]
ilk öncelikle Günaydınlar burada
sizlerle beraber olmaktan son derece
mutlu olduğunu ifade etmek istiyorum Ve
Organizasyon komitesine de gönülden
teşekkür ediyorum tabi huzurunuza
çıkmadan önce yakın çevremde beraber
çalıştığım bir grup arkadaşıma ne
anlatayım diye sordu bilim diplomasisi
mi bilim liderliğini yükseköğretimi
kanser
Evet hocam nereye Steve ise herkesi
Anladım dediler ben de size başaramazsın
diyenlere inat hikayemi anlatacağım
heyecanlıyım Çünkü aslında bir çocuğun
hikayesini sizlerle paylaşacağım bugüne
kadar pek çok küresel arenada
400'ün üzerinde konferans vermiş birisi
ama bir çocuğun hikayesini anlatacağım
için çok heyecanlı olduğunu söylemem
gerekiyor 10 liralık 1977 yılında
Batman'ın Beşiri ilçesinde beş bin
nüfuslu bir coğrafyada dünyaya geldim
ilk orta ve lise eğitimimi ve şirin
ilgili okullarından aldıktan sonra 94
yılında Dicle Üniversitesini kazandım
1098 yılında üniversiteyi bitirdikten
sonra Türkiye birincisi olarak İzmir
Yüksek Teknoloji enstitüsü'nde araştırma
görevliliği ve hemen akabinde ODTÜ'de
hazırlık yüksek lisans ve doktora
eğitimi almak üzere eğitime ve 6 the 30
eğitim devam ederken NATO'nun tüm
dünyadan dök ülkeye özel verdiği bursu
kazanarak verdi kalın görüşürüz kalkar
olan ya da kanser araştırma merkezinde
çalışmalarda bulundum
bu
yılında ilk öğretim üyesi olarak göreve
başladım ve İnanılmaz bir şekilde ulusal
ve küresel arenada proje desteklerinden
laboratuvarını kurdu Make elimi
oluşturdum Ve tabii ki etkilerinin çok
geniş verebilir vardı
laboratuvarda mezun ettiği
öğrencilerinden şu an Harvard
Üniversitesi'nde Yüzyıl'ı ile you tahta
mayo clinic'te dünyanın en iyi
üniversitelerinde Türkiye'deki çok
Üniversitesi'nde öğrencilerin çalıştığı
söylemem lazım
ama belki yaşına gelmeden kendi
araştırma ekibinde çalışan bir öğrenci
profesörlüğü at
bu İnanılmaz bir şekilde İlerleyen bir
yerden bahsediyorum burada size 2007
yılında doktora tezim Türkiye'de tüm
alanlardan ve açık Ara yılın doktora
tezi ödülünü aldı iyice geldiğim yıldan
itibaren her sene neredeyiz neredeyse
yılın en fazla bilimsel yürüten öğretim
üyesi oldu Türkiye bilimler
akademisinden bilim kahramanları Derneği
nden yılın bilim insanı ödülleri ve
Eczacıbaşı Holding'in tıp alanında Güven
Hastanesi'nin tıp alanında ve yine
Eczacılık akademisinin Eczacılık
alanında verdiği tıp ödüllerini
yeni bir yönetim birimi olarak elde
ettim İstanbul Teknik Üniversitesi'nin
Hacettepe Üniversitesi'nin Kocaeli
Üniversitesi'nin pek çok üniversitenin
bir ödüllerini aldı ve daha sonra da
2014 yılında uluslararası genç liderler
ve Girişimciler Derneği nden bilimsel
önderlik alanında Türkiye'nin en
başarılı insan öldürüldü al
çok değişik bir yılın sonunda Türkiye
inovasyon üstün başarı ödüllerinden
yılın bilim giydiriyor ve Burada
gördüğünüz gibi inanılmaz ve yukarı
doğru gider yeter yerden bahsediyorum
size ve sonra 2013 yılında küresel
arenada başlayan bir başarı hikayesi bu
dünya ekonomik forumu'nun kurduğu
küresel genç akademiye tüm dünyadan en
yüksek puanla seçilen bir insan olduğunu
2015 yılında Dünya ilimler Akademisi'ne
yine Asya'dan en yüksek puanla seçilen
bilim insanı olma başarısı elde ettim
heso dünya Bilimler Akademisi Amerika'da
Suşehri Ford Otosan mısın tüm Dünya'dan
çok sınırlı sayıda seçtiği insanlardan
biri olarak bilim diplomasisi ve bilim
liderlik
etkinliklerine seçelim ve küresel alanda
400'ün üzerinde az önce de ifade ettiğim
gibi dünyanın 70'den fazla ülkesinde pek
çok formunda gün yaparım Forumu
bakıyorum mantarlı formu Birleşmiş
Milletler Avrupa parlamentosu gün ya bir
formunun 140 ülkeden 3000 birincilerinin
devlet başkanının katıldığı bir forumda
bilim diplomasisi başlıklı bir oturumda
açılış konuşmasını gerçekleştirdi ben
sana buradaki zirvede 21 21 yılının
ağustos'unda İtalya'da düzenlenen geceye
bir araştırma Bakanlığı zirvesinde davet
edilen bir rektör oldu
bu inanılmaz gidiyorlar şey değil mi
12 basının ilgisi
ve her ulusal her küresel düzeyde yazılı
görsel ve sosyal medyada bütün bu
başarıların inanılmaz bir yansıması ve
Tabiki toplumda inanılmaz bir karşılığı
oldu Kimisi filmdeki inanılmaz artık
imkansız ulaştığını Kimisi Türkiye'nin
en başarılı insan olduğunu Kimisi de bu
adama Gözümüz gibi bakmalıyız diyordu ve
basın yansımaları Tabii ki ülkenin
gençlerini ve çocukların da ilgisini
çekiyor Ve tabii ki onlar için bir model
oluyordu kariyerinin 15 saniye Zirvesi
100'den fazla devlet başkanı 1500 dünya
indirilir bulunduğu gün ya Ekonomik
Forumu'nda 2013 yılında tüm dünyadan
akademik mükemmeliyet topluma hizmet ve
dünyayı değiştirme potansiyeli
Dolayısıyla almış olduğu yılın bilim
lideri yılın bilim insanı öldürdü bu ne
gördüğünüz gibi her şey inanılmaz
Biliyoruz tabii Tüm bu süreçte hiçbir
zaman ülkenin çocuklarını onların
hayallerini ve hedeflerini büyütmeyi ve
onlara karşı provakatif olmayı hiçbir
zaman terk etmedim Sadece ülkemiz
çocuklarına değil Suriyeli mülteci
kamplarında Afrika'nın pek çok
bölgesinde dünyanın bütün çocukların
hayallerini büyütmeye o konforlu
donlarını Terk etmeye hedeflerinin
peşinden koşulan noktasında
çalışmalarına emek sarf ettim ve Aslında
hepsinin temelinde dünyayı değiştirme
motivasyonu vardır
abone ol
O benim de servise giderseniz çeviririm
her şey olmaz gidiyordu gördüğünüz gibi
işte Batman'ın Beşiri ilçesinde doğmuş
bir çocuk dünya ekonomik forumu'na g20ye
birleşmiş milletleri Avrupa
parlamentosu'na böyle miydi gerçekten
var ya da bu dışarıdan bir insanın Benim
yaşamımı kariyerime baktığında
gördüklerim miydi ne vardı buzdolabının
arkasında Aslında asıl sizinle paylaşmak
istediğim şey bu hikaye tabii ki o bir
çizgi değildi inanılmaz daldır İnanılmaz
yıkılışlar İnanılmaz sürü neler Ve
inanılmaz zorluklarla mücadele ve bu
mücadelenin çok erken dönemde
başladığını sizde ifade etmek istiyorum
Birlik 4 şu anda bir şey o birbirini
insan olarak karşınızdayım dışarıdan
baktığımızda daha zirvesinde bir insan
Peki o zirveye birisi bebeği kucağında
getir bırakmış mıydı ya da bir parti
almış tarihi Ben kanatlarını çırpa çırpa
mı koymuştu ya da sürülerek bütün
yoldaki zorlukları bilerek yeterli ki O
süre daha çıktığımızda açtı vücudunuzda
oluşan yaralarda beraber gitmiştir Eğer
bir şey 11 Aralık 1977 yılında doğdum da
Ya aslında doğamaz bir çocuk olarak
Çünkü annem bana hamileyken
geçirdiği bir hastalık Dolayısıyla bu
çocuk doğamaz bunu almamız gerekiyor
demişler Annem devletmiş Anne karnında
başlayan bir mücadelede de işte
buradayım
Yok bir şey ama sonra Çünkü
sağlık problemleri olan bir çocuk böyle
şey yapamaz bu yaşayamaz çocuk bütün
çocukluğu boyunca birçok hastalık
geçiriyor Ve
inanılmaz zayıf ve cılız bir çocukluk bu
t77 yıllardan bahsediyorum bir şey
ilçesinde doktor yok Babam işte
hastalığında sürekli bir şeyden Batman
hekime götürüyor üç sefer yolda öldüğünü
söyledi babam bana arada bir pile da var
ve size bakmadan arasında üç sefer
dağdan geri döndüğünü biraz geldikten
sonra benim bir daha öksürük pastili
ağlayarak yaşama gelin ömrümü anlatın
bana
doğalgazdan yaşayamaz ve İşte karşınızda
yaşayan birisi var
çıkamadı devam ediyor sonra inanılmaz
Hareketli bir çocuk Annem gördüğünüz
böyle bir şeyin içine koruduğunu
söylüyor beni çekmeyelim diye Bence
zıplayarak çıkmaya başlayınca bu defa
hanımefendi ayağından beni bu altındaki
Demir parçalara ve Bağları bağlama
başlıyor beşiğinden çekmeyelim diye çok
hareketli bir çocuk dört buçuk yaşında
ilkokula gönderiliyor öğretmenleri
okuyamaz diyor bu çocuk eğitimi alamaz
diyor ve çok iyi hatırlıyorum ilk Okulun
ilk günü dört buçuk yaşında deri ailem
Okuldan geri aldı ve Bir sene sonra
tekrar okuluna devam etti
var
anlatabilir hikaye vardı bana
çocukluğumdaki koku çocukluğunda
dayımın kütüphanenin gazetenin olmadığı
bir ilçede Türkiye'nin gündemini takip
etmek için ki 60'lı yılların
türkiye'sinde ilçeden beş kilometre
ileride bir tren istasyonuna gidip Otel
istasyonunda köylülerin Diyarbakır ve
Batman ıslatmak için götürdükleri
Yoğurdun üzerindeki Bafra cır çöpe
atılmış gazetelerini getirip üzerindeki
çamurlu silip Okulu hikayesini
anlatmıştı
dayıma dair bir çocuktum ve bütün
kitapların
üzerindeydi ve 5 kilo kilometre yürümem
gerek yoktu Ben okumaya başladım ve
babamın anlattığı bir hikaye elektriğin
olmadığı bir yerde amcamla ders çalışmak
için şu gördüğünüz lambanın etrafında
birbirlerine çekip çıkan kavgada evin
yarışını anlatmıştı babam bana o kadar
gidilmeye basıyordum ve her taraf
aydınlatıyoruz inanılmaz okuyordum ve
okumaya devam ediyorum okuyan bir
yazıyor da tabi
ilkokul 4 Atatürk'ün kişiliğini okuyorum
Cumhuriyet Bayramında ve bir kompozisyon
yazmıştım üçüncü oldu kompozisyon
yarışmasında neden gitti öğretmenlerinin
neden diye sordu bunu yazmış olamazsın
dedi
bu Bursa yazmış olamazsın ama biz hileli
Hani bir açık kapı bırakıp sana
üçüncülük verdim oysa neden anlamıştım
ne demek istediğini başka birini yazdım
yerini alta yazıp yönetip yaşamaya
başlayınca sorgulama açtım Ne öğretmeni
dedi anlamıştı bu ortaokuldayken
o Liselere geçiş sınavına girdim
kazanamazsın dediler gerçekten
kazanamadım orada Çünkü bildiğimiz
sınavda birtakım şairler oluşmuştu
kazanamadım burayı ve sonra bir de başka
bir kompozisyon yarışması hiç
doldurdum yine sordum öğretmeni neden
yokum değil hakkımı aradım ya
bu
kompozisyonu Sen yazmış olamazsın dedi
Ben de oldum abi bize diyor versin Sen
yazmış olamazsın dedi bana istediğiniz
konuda bir başlıkların oturup yazayım
dedim Otur yaz dedi ormanların Bir
ülkenin ekonomik kalkınmasına ve
yaşamına katkıları oturdum ve yazdım ve
okuyunca edebiyat öğretmenimiz olamaz mı
böyle bir şey olsa olmuştur Ben her
hafta o öğretmenin gözetiminde yapmaya
devam etti
bu ve sonra tabi üniversite sınavı
ilçede terörün yoğun olduğu dönemler
doğru düzgün öğretmen yok Dershane zaten
Yok bakmadım dershane var üniversiteye
gitmem gerekiyor ama herkes gidemezsin
diyor Olmaz böyle bir şey diyor bu
ülkede üniversiteyi kazanmak Yok öyle
bir şey diyor ve ben gördüğünüz ilçeler
çıktı cumartesi pazar kendim çalışarak
Dershane paramı kazanarak Batman'da bir
her ucuz Dershanesi'ne kayboldum ve
hafta sonları karanlıkta simitleri
Batman'a giden bazen traktör bazen
kamyon batıdan biçerdöver Vakfında ne
çıkarsa dershaneye gitti
Ben 7 kardeşiz biz sodalı diye O ev
Tabii
evin televizyon izleme yemek yeme
babamın Ofisi tüm misafirlerin
ağırlandığı kavganın her şey olduğu yer
şu köşede dedim çalışma O da O
gördüğünüz sehpanın üzerinde ayağının
[Müzik]
üniversite sınavına hazırlandığı ve
ve en çok kalabalık olduğunda ya da çok
soğuk olduğunda şu alt tarafta bir küçük
şey göreceksiniz şurada küçücük bir
pencere baktım santimetre karelik Bodrum
orada senin Bodrum'u kirliydi oraya
çalışma odasına çözülmüştü Kışın çok
soğuk ve Yazın çok sıcak olduğunda seri
ve sıcak oluyordu Tamam seni orada günde
18650 hayatımın en büyük başarısını elde
ettim Dicle Üniversitesini kazandım 231
olarak
Bu web sitesini getirdiğin devam edersen
olmak istemiştim olamazsın dediler
sen olamazsın
bir dolama girdiğim sınavlara ve
olamadım ama vazgeçmek var mı Yok çok
sıkı çalıştım kendimi çok önemli bir
özelliği vardır da hayatın her şey
kendim öğrendim öyle öğretmenler çok
birşey öğrenmediğini söyleyebilirim size
olarak kopya girdim
hocalarım hiç kimse olamaz böyle birşey
çok sağlam güçlü diye o zaten oturup
inanılmaz ders çalışmıştım tepsi bu ve
ben bu sınava giderken de Batman'da beni
tanıyan herkes boşu boşuna gitme Kendini
yorma Çünkü bir batmanlının böyle bir
Sınavda başarılı olma şansı yok Çünkü
işte tanıdığın ettiğin kimse yok ve
Dediğim gibi ben Türkiye birisi olarak
iyi dereotu edilmişti motor İngilizce
eğitim ve 9 ayda geçmem gereken bir
sınav hayatındaki herkes İngilizceyi bir
yılda öğrenemeyeceğini söyledi
ama sakın gitme bu senedin altına
Elimizi atma oy veren imzamı attım günde
beş istedim ezberliyorum İngilizce'de ve
o Türk tarihinde tarihi Yazdım 4 ay 15
günde İngilizce girdim
bu ne olursun da başladığında her şey
vardır kazanamaz yapamaz başaramaz
bizlerin titreye gitmiştim oku diye
başarabilecek bilgiye aynı tekniği
Amerika'da yaşadım başarabilecek miyim
diye 6 ay sonra döndüğümde o
üniversitenin en başarılı
akademisyenlerinden biri ve dönerken
bölge seni burada iş alalım diye bana
söylemişlerdi
E tabi yılın teyze ödülünü aldım iyice
döndüm araştırma görevlisi Doçent ile
başvuracağım asla olmaz dediler daha
Yardımcı Doçent bile değilsin başvuru
hiç kimseyi oldu tabii
Bilim insanlarından bir tanesi ilkokul 4
yazıyor olamaz diye bu bana
bakınca insanların
devam ediyor ya o zaman ilkokul 4 şimdi
bir şeyler devam ediyor
abone ol
bu Şubat yeni bölümü aldım kimsenin
yapilisinin
başvurması dediler bana Kendimi asla
aday göstermedi başvurdum başvurmamız
kim dinler Bu
[Müzik]
nasıl aldığını biliyoruz Bu nasıl
başardığını biliyoruz arkasındaki gücü
biliyoruz diğer insanlar her İnsaf artık
Dünya Ekonomik Forumu'nda nasıl bir
referans nasıl bir metre küp
uygulanabilir ki birisi bu oldu
arkadaşlar ve iterek körlüğü ve tekniği
Parti il yönetim kurulu başkanlığında
ikiye ayrıldığı insanlar yapabilir mi
deliyim bu çocuğu ama yaptım yapıyorum
iyice şu anda Türkiye'nin ve dünyanın
model üniversitelerinden bir tanesi
olarak yoluna Tabii ki devam ediyor
Neden Neden bu kadar çok emek neden bu
kadar çok çalışıyorum
ben bu çocuğa karşı Gönül bodrumlar be
içimde yaşatıyorum onu geçmişte yaşadığı
zorluklar karşılaştığı sıkıntılar
haksızlıklar bu çocuğu gidebileceği en
üst noktaya götürmeye al geçmiş bir
bilim insanıyım Led hangi os göreceğiz
Biz Neden Çünkü 4.53 bir yerleştiğinde
evlendi 200 bin yıldır var olan
insanoğlu ölümsüzlük iksiri elde
edemediği için bıraktığı izler yarattığı
eserlerle ölümsüzlüğü elde ediyor Bu
çocuğu ölümsüz kılmak istiyorum da ne
yaptın izler hayatına dokundu insanlar
bilimsel eserler kitaplar yayınlar ve
şimdi İzmir Yüksek Teknoloji
enstitüsü'nde ki değişim ve dönüşüm ile
bu çocuğun ölümsüzlüğü elde etmek
istiyorum şu Çünkü bilim ve eğitim bir
Coğrafyadan göç ettiği zaman beraberinde
hayatın kendisini yaşam kalitesini ve
zenginliği dal götürüyor O nedenle bu
coğrafyaya eğitiminde birinin
algınlığını ve bu toplumun her birini
ayakları üzerinde dimdik duran eğitime
ve bilime inanan ve böylece ülkenin
aydınlık geleceğine katkı sunan bir
video olarak geçmesi inanıyor ve bunu
yapabilmemiz intake yolunu her birimizi
ama Her birimizin eğitimine ve tabii ki
birimi olan İnançla gerçekleşecek bu
yolculukta bana eşlik eden iki arkadaşım
var çok güçlü gitti referans nokta O
çok çalış
ve kariyerini adanmış bir hayat yaşamış
bir bilim insanı bir aktris var
karşımızda çok çalıştım
hayatımı alalım Bu kaliteli ikincisi
yaşamındaki hiçbir zorluk Ama hiçbir
zorluk veriyorum lan çevrildi birileri
Superman birileri güvenlik Herkes bir
şeyler söylüyor ama hayatın boyunca
hiçbir zorluk yaşadığım hiçbir sıkıntı
beni yolumdan hayallerimden ve
hedeflerinden vazgeçmedim
bu
Kurtuluş Savaşı'nda bir fotoğraftır bu
bu fotoğrafta üç Grup insan var bir
tanesi bu
vatan işler altında Anadolu'nun bütün
müziklerini kadın erkek savaşa
çağırıyorum diyen Bir liderin
daveti ne elimde ne varsa katılan bir
Mehmet görüyorsunuz burada üstüne başına
baktığımızda Ayakkabısı yok Bir çağırıp
vardır çoraptan bozma bir çağırıp
üzerindeki yırtık pırtık paltosunu
mahzunluğu görüyorsunuz
O kim var dendiğinde sağına soluna
bakmadan elinde avucunda ne var diye
bakmadan kalkıp koşan bir yiğit
görüyorsunuz Bu geçici bir insan daha şu
bir efendim
Bu bakış açısına gözlerine bakar mısınız
ama hiçbir şey yapmadığı gibi beğenmiyor
savaşa gideli savaştan dönemi fedakarlık
yapanı elinde avucunda ki ile Ülkesi
için mücadele eden beğenmiyor üçüncü
grup insan şu anda dedikodu yapanlar
ama hiçbir şey yapmayan ama dedikodu
yapanlar bugünün dünyasında
türkiye'sinde her sektörde her alanda
aynı şey Devam ediyorum her birimiz
İnsanlık adına Ülkemiz adına iyi bir
şeyler yapmak üzere mücadele ederken
onun dedikodusunu yapanlarda değerlenir
etrafımızda ama kim olarak dikkate alır
ki bize düşen Tabii ki yolcu büyüme
İmam sözüdür beni kendinizi
biliyorsunuzdur yolunuzu yürürken önce
sizi görmezler günler sonra size
gülerler sonrasında kavga ederler ama
günün sonunda Siz kazanırsınız tabi
Hamdi'nin yaşadığı bölgeleri bugün
2000'li yıllardan soralım sözleri vardır
böyle Seni Görmezden gelirler sonra sana
gülerler ve sonra senden nefret ederler
başarılı insan sevmezler Tabii ki Ah ah
her birimiz Hayal olduğumuzu kendinizi
inşa ediyoruz Aslında kendimiz
yaratıyoruz farkımız alıyoruz Bu evdeyim
Bu bir sosyal adam Ben Kendi
hayatıma alabildiğine çok evliliği
sürdürme ve evlerimiz sayısını Tabii ki
atmaya çalıştım ilk orta lise sınıf
arkadaşlarımdan hala o büyüğümüz ilçede
bir dükkanda Bir bakkal dükkanı işleten
çobanlık yapan arkadaşların arkadaşlar
ve hepside kucaklıyorum tabii ki ama ben
kendi yolculuğu güldüm ve kendini
gerçekleştirmeye devam ediyorum Ufuk
dediğimiz şey derdi Dostlar ufka
Vardığımızda Gözünüz başka bir uyku
görüyorsa kör olsun üzeredir bir Çünkü
varlığınız her Ufuk Sizi başka bir usta
götürür hayalleri hedefleri de böyledir
her hayalin nedir bizi başka bir hayale
ve başka bir hedefe götürür değişmesi
gereken bir dünya
16 kapağının tamamında dünyanın her
coğrafyasında bu tipler savaşlar
problemler
göçler demokrasi sorunları insan hakları
sorunları kadın hakları sorunları ama
vazgeçmek yok ve çok çalışmak var bu 26
Eylül 2020'de Urla'nın gecesinin on iki
buçuğunda Dağ Başında Bir ormanda
yürürken yüreğiyle dökülenlerin kaleme
yansıması bir tek var aydınlatma
biliyorsa gecenin zifiri karanlığında
yeryüzünü bir tek insan değiştirebiliyor
sa koskoca bir toplumun kaderini bir tek
yıldız yol gösterebiliyor Sen yolunu
kaybetmişlere bir tek halin son
verebiliyorsa cehaletini zifiri
karanlığına Sende bir bu olmalı
aydınlatmalı yol göstermeli ve Dünya'yı
değiştirmek için sakın unutma bütün
karanlıkların ömrü bir tek bu yana ve
sen ayağa kalkana kadardır
sakin ol meydan okudu gülümse ve dünyaya
gelmiştir Çok teşekkür ederiz